home
that
this
this the population of New York City's is staggering
8.3 million people 18 if thirty eight americans lives in New York City
meaning there are more New Yorkers
in vegetarians in the United States this populous city fits on 303 square miles
it everyone in Manhattan was on the ground level
there would only be 20 people
Nashville for comparison as more than 50 times the space
and and had nearly doubled in population during the workday
you can just have to space more people ride the subway daily in New York
in their people living in Los Angeles even more mind-blowing
at this very second there are more people the New York City Subway
in live in Boulder Colorado for the subways much larger than you would think
if the tracks for Lady into and they would stretch from the city affordable
slices
to the capital deep dish New Yorker spend three times the national average
on rent
and when it comes to Chinese food the use $100 million takeout boxes a year
that's for takeout boxes than American homes occupied by homeowners
it is large this best cities actually on the 18th most populous city in the world
though it may not be the biggest city to new yorkers
feels like the center of the universe.